grâce aux nouvelles aires protégées par
l'organisme conservation de la nature
canada
cette tortue sera plus à l'abri de
l'activité humaine les terrains qu'on
protège et font à peu près 2 ha c'est
des petites propriétés mais qui sont
connus le polo l'importance écologique
cet endroit est utilisé entre eux par
des jeunes tortues qui viennent de
naître pour aller s'abriter s'alimenter
et hiberner il ne resterait que sa
tortue molle à épines en âge de se
reproduire au québec par avant on a
retrouvé dans la rivière richelieu dans
la rivière des outaouais à l'ouest de
montréal aussi même avec des recherches
depuis quelques décennies on n'en trouve
plus du tout dans ces régions le les
centres de recherche zoo de granby
s'emploie à les sauver depuis 2010 en
servant de pouponnières bon an mal an
environ 200 e
on recueille qu'on amène ici dans les
incubateurs de laboratoires de recherche
d'environ 170 à 180 individus qui vont
naître
déjà 1700 baby ont été relâchées dans la
rivière aux brochets il devenait urgent
de leur créer un refuge
malheureusement les riverains de
l'esport les berges à leur état naturel
beaucoup dériverait prétend avoir des
murets de béton par exemple ou en vue de
la végétation
c'est plus difficile d'aller se reposer
sur les berges cirque berges naturelles
saison protégés ne bénéficient pas coup
tordu en protégeant la propriété qu'on
annonce aujourd'hui on a trouvé des
espèces de plantes qui sont forts aussi
est menacée donc en protégeant site est
tortueux on vient protéger toutes sortes
d'espèces conservation de la nature
canada espère que d'ici quelques années
les tortues molle à épines pourront se
reproduire d'elle-même sans aide humaine
en attendant il faudra continuer les
efforts pour le protéger si alexandre
révélé le radio canada